dafür bilden ist jemanden töten
herzlich willkommen zu einem neuen video
mit mir macht der magische kick der
magischen vier korea kam magische
miesmuschel die werden wie heute mal
befragen in dieser folge mit groove
werden wir sie befragen
eine weiße war okay und so geht's los
wenden sie jetzt so wir stellen hatten
frage und dann dann ziehen wir an diesem
dinge auf dem touchscreen so genau ich
ganz gar nicht irgendwie also maxi daran
und dann wird die uns antwort geben okay
die erste frage was hältst du davon dass
wir soweit games auf golf spielen ja
keine ahnung der muschel was heißt schon
von sg im ok dann schau mal hier rein in
rosa sowie games 4 sowie games 42 games
okay leute wir sind darunter die westlb
muss schon erkannt unserem nickname mag
ich mich so schnell wie die mitte gehen
ja das kommt zu spät
drechsel okay jetzt wahrscheinlich raus
wichtig ist ihr auch noch ein bisschen
jetzt okay dann sag ich ja nein die kann
diese muss auf den welt passiert
ich würde jetzt antworten und jetzt
kannst du sehen was auf dem bildschirm
passiert darf ich die auf machen ja oder
nein kein 22 flocke kein zweifel und
datentypen gesehen
constantini das ist mir zu früh das mir
zu früh namen soll er angreifen was mit
der iss erwartet die manchmal auf bevor
sich bei jedem einzelnen zu fragen weil
die milch muss die miesmuschel müsst ihr
wissen ist ein bisschen in die civ wie
man sagt 'die weiß ich nicht zu
entscheiden
die sagt dann so was wie wo soll ich das
wissen so die klassische frau dann sage
ich immer so ok angreifen angreifen
ja was ist interessant ist ja dann
kannst du machen wir glück als würde sie
anschauen würden greifen wir uns den
typen mal hier an wo leser sondern auch
die zuschauer in der zwischenzeit malen
lassen kein lassen
aber er macht jetzt natürlich weg lege
diesen ekel move da wenn mich natürlich
ein abgang ok dann würde ich sagen soll
ein bisschen weiter equipment ergebnis
heute
wobei es natürlich auch denken dass er
tut wahrscheinlich zeit da hab ich ihn
angreifen darf ich wieder angreifen er
schlägt nicht
darf ich im bitte hauen ergreift mich an
yamana schon wieder da drüben hat seine
eltern klappt er will dass ich tippe
siehst du das das ist das ist mein vater
hat es ist deine schuld dass wir dort
gestorben sind
du wirst du wirst dich gelöscht
den speck okay wir sind in der runde
entnervt nachdem wir uns gerade um
gebracht hast was du sagst du dazu
vielleicht mal nicht umbringen
ok ich nehme zweite kiste macht das
wirst du dich immer fragen weil es real
ich habe dies auch bereits die du am
anfang auch herausgefordert
ja das stimmt schon ich habe ich einfach
zu viel gefragt am anfang dachte ich am
ende so okay dass man den typen
darstelle das nächste schwert nehmen
dass du findest aber als ich das schon
so nah nein da diese aber darum sie
kisten oder mehrere das märchen danger
glück geht nicht abstieg den du siehst
angreifen
okay noch mal drüber nachdenkt alles
klar
magische fucking dadurch böse wörter
sagen meine aufnahme eigentlich dafür
bilder brown ist ja sowas darf die töten
töten
roman damit ihn töten hätte mich ja ja
etwas mit was mit dem ihr den frechen
stalins alles klar
wo kann der hat gerade erst wieder in
eine phase auf einmal oben angreifen
dafür abstauben man sei nicht so gemeint
habe ich bitte diesen typen töten
dann stand ich bin natürlich voll okay
dann hole ich mir den typen was auch auf
hinten auf nein wahrscheinlich als wird
das auf den andern geht leise schwer
täglich die rottaler jo alter wie nah
ist an mir dran waterpark alter schwer
das wird richtig ärgert probier doch mal
wieder wirklich schon wieder das nicht
schon wieder
na jetzt kommt auch noch eine auf danke
sie kräftig an
junge junge junge junge das war so kloos
alter schwede
wenn's kuppeldach gehen
ja aber dafür muss er sofort regen aber
was nicht ist kann ja hier oben aber so
etwas wie werden diese hoch schaffen
oder wenn nicht anders werden wir auf
dem weg nach oben sterben können
unmöglicher weise sterben
also irgendwie jetzt auch intuitiv
gesagt dass man da schon sterben kann
oliver leider kommt kommt er eigentlich
ja es wird nämlich garantiert jemand
kommen die frage ist wirklich wann der
gegner kommt welche sprung überleben
magische miesmuschel ich muss springen
ich muss springen wie er selbst sagt das
ist hey hey was ist los man jetzt ganz
viel springt dafür wirst mich kurz aber
ganz du musst das spring und ihr da oben
hättest du easy entscheiden können das
ja auch drei level ja man einen ganzen
tag lang hat es habe mir einfach
jetzt haben wir zwei gegner und sie
werden uns sehr gerne töten wollen
marlies busch land irgendeine chance
dieses match zu gewinnen
oh shit leute wir haben offiziell keine
chance ist der world matchplay noch
schaffen es immer besser zahlen aber
jetzt jetzt sind die geld auf die
chatpartner das ist so natürlich nicht
sogar alles gute
auf typen der angeln sie werden diesen
halt geil auf die festplatte ist einfach
so jetzt kommt der hund leider ja als ob
er mich jetzt tue wie wollt ihr 60
als ob ihr mich jetzt die wand trennt
als ob ihr mich to be want to be one sie
dich ihr dummen hub als ob ihr mich
grade to wie wollt ihr seid doch so
scheiße
ja wahrscheinlich bett